(angelic music)
- From no French model,
breathes the muse tonight
the scene she draws is horrid, not polite.
She dips her pen in
terror, will ye shrink?
Shall foreign critics
teach you how to think?
Had Shakespeare's magic
dignified the stage?
If timid laws had
schooled the insipid age?
Had Hamlet's specter
trod the midnight round?
Or Banquo's issue been in vision crowned?
Free as your country,
Britons, be your scene.
Be nature now, and now invention queen.
Be vice alone corrected and restrained.
Can crimes be punished
by a bard enchained?
Shall the bold censor
back be sent to school,
and told, "This is not
nice, that is not rule."
The French no crimes of magnitude admit.
They seldom startle, just alarm the pit.
The tragic Greeks, with
nobler license wrote
nor veiled the eye, but
plucked away the mote.
Whatever passion prompted, was their game
not delicate, while
chastisement their aim.
Electra now a parent's blood demands.
Now parricide distains the Theban's hands.
And love incestuous
knots his nuptial bands.
Such is our scene, from real life it rose.
Tremendous picture of domestic woes.
If terror shake you, or soft pity move,
if dreadful pangs o'ertake unbridled love.
Excuse the bard, who
from your feeling draws
all the reward he aims at, your applause.
(applause)
(angelic music)
(thunder roaring)
- What awful silence!
How these antique towers and vacant courts
dull the suspended soul,
till expectation wears the cast of fear
and fear half-ready to become devotion,
mumbles a kind of mental orison.
I met a peasant, and inquired my way.
The churl, not rude of speech,
but like the tenant of
some night-haunted ruin,
bore an aspect of
horror, worn to habitude.
None there, said he, are welcome,
but now and then a pious
mass-priest, and the poor,
to whom the Countess deals
her alms on covenant,
that each revolving night
they beg of heaven the health
of her son's soul and her own.
What precious mummery!
Her son in exile,
she wastes on monks and
beggars his inheritance,
for his soul's health!
I never knew a woman but loved our bodies
or our souls too well.
- Methought I heard a stranger's voice.
What lack you, sir?
- Good fellow, who inhabits here?
- I do.
- Belike this castle is not thine.
- Belike so,
but be it whose it may,
this is no haunt For revellers
and gallants, pass your way.
- Thou churl!
Is this your Gallic hospitality?
Thy lady, on my life,
would not thus rudely
chide from her presence
a bewildered knight.
- Angels defend us!
What a reprobate!
Thou know'st my lady then!
Thou know'st her not.
Canst thou in hair-cloths
vex those dainty limbs?
Canst thou on reeking
pavements and cold marble,
in meditation pass the live-long night?
- Father grey-beard, I cry you mercy.
- Time was, my lord,
the Count of Narbonne,
a prosperous gentleman.
Were he alive, we should not
know these moping melancholies.
Heaven rest his soul!
I marvel not my lady
cherishes his remembrance,
for he was comely to sight,
and wondrous goodly built.
They say, his son Count Edmund's
mainly like him.
- What if I bring tidings of Count Edmund?
- Last night the raven croak'd,
and from the bars of our
lodge-fire flitted a messenger.
I knew no good would follow.
Oh, no, no, he must not here alas!
I prithee, he must not here set foot.
Does my old master's heir
still breathe this vital air?
Is he in France?
I would make a weary pilgrimage
to kiss his gracious hands,
and at his feet lay my old bones.
- But say, why Narbonne's heir
from Narbonne's lands is banished
driven by a ruthless mother?
- Ah sir, 'tis hard indeed,
but spare his mother.
Such virtue never dwelt in female form.
But so,
count Edmund being not
sixteen, a lusty youth,
his father's very image.
I come to the point,
her name was Beatrice.
Aye, Beatrice
a rogueish eye, she
never would look at me.
This Beatrice
but hark!
My lady comes.
Retire a while beyond the yews,
anon I'll tell you more.
(angelic music)
'Tis ever thus.
At break of morn, she
hies to yonder abbey,
and prostate o'er some monumental stone,
seems more to wait her
doom, than ask to shun it.
But hush.
Who moves up yonder avenue?
It is he, Benedict,
my lady's confessor, with Friar Martin.
Quick hide thee hence,
should that same meddling
monk observe our conference,
there were fine work toward.
Loiter about yon grange,
I come to thee there.
(chorus singing)
- Ay!
Sift her, sift her I tell thee, brother,
this woman was not cast in human mould.
Ten such would foil a council,
would unbuild our Roman church
in her, devotion's real.
She prays because she feels,
and feels, because a sinner.
- What is this secret
sin, this untold tale,
that art cannot extract,
nor penance cleanse?
Loss of a husband, sixteen
years enjoyed and dead as many
could not stamp such sorrow.
- My mind has more than once imputed blood
to this incessant mourner.
Beatrice, the damsel
for whose sake in exile
she holds her only son, has never,
since the night of his
incontinence, been seen or heard of.
- 'Tis clear, 'tis clear!
- I have oft shifted
my discourse to murder.
She notes it not.
Her muscles hold their place
no sudden flushing, no faltering lip.
I've fixed on love,
The failure of the sex,
and aptest cause of each attendant crime.
- Aye, brother, there we
master all their craft.
- Still, brother, do you err?
The Count Her husband,
so adored and so lamented
won not her fancy,
till the nuptial rites had
with the sting of pleasure
taught her passion.
- Then whither turn to
worm her secret out?
- I know not that, nay.
One unguarded moment may
disclose this mystic tale
then, brother, what a harvest.
Or soon, or late, a praying
woman must become our spoil.
- Her zeal may falter.
- I nurse her in new horrors,
form her tenants to
fancy visions, phantoms,
and report them.
She mocks their fond
credulity, but trust me,
her memory retains their colouring.
- This is masterly.
- Oh, were I seated high as my ambition
I'd place this naked foot
on necks of monarchs.
- By humbler arts our humble fabric rose.
Win power by craft,
wear it with ostentation.
Gain to the Holy See this fair
domain and a crimson bonnet
may reward your toils.
- Never, while Edmund lives.
This steady woman can ne'er
be pious with so many virtues.
Justice is interwoven in her frame.
Nor will she wrong the
son she will not see.
She loves him not,
yet is mistress of his fortunes
usurp'd from her own wants,
she sets apart a scanty
portion only for her ward,
Young Adeliza.
- 'Twere wise to school this maiden,
lead the train of young
ideas to a fancied object.
A mental spouse.
- This is already done.
But Edmund's death were hopes more solid.
- First report him dead.
His letters intercepted.
- Greatly thought.
Lo, where comes our patroness, leave me
- Alas!
Must guilt ground our very virtues?
Grow they on sin alone, and not on grace?
While Narbonne lived,
my fully-sated soul thought none unhappy
for it did not think!
Well!
Peace is fled,
ne'er to return!
Nor dare I snap the thread of life.
Eternity has scope enough to punish me,
tho' I should borrow a few short hours
to sacrifice to charity.
- I sought you, lady.
- Happily I'm found.
Who needs the widow's mite?
- None asks your aid.
Your gracious foresight
still prevents occasion.
- No more of this, good father.
I suspect none of your
holy order of dissembling.
Suspect not me of loving flattery.
Will it give me virtues?
- The church could seal your
pardon, but you scorn it.
Yours are Pagan virtues,
as such I praise them,
but as such condemn them.
- Father, my crimes are Pagan.
Why shakes my soul with nightly terrors?
'Tis from within I tremble.
Death would be felicity.
What joys have I?
I have lost my husband.
My own decree has banished my own son.
- Last night I dreamt your
son was with the blessed.
- Would heaven he were!
- Do you then wish his death?
- Should I not wish him blest?
- Madam, I must not hear this language.
You do abuse my patience.
It ill beseems my holy
function to give countenance
by lending ear to such pernicious tenets.
I am wrapt beyond my bearing!
Your son is dead!
- Father, we no prophetic demon bear
within our breast but conscience.
That has spoken.
'Tis that voice has told me,
'twas my son's birth, not his mortality,
must drown my soul in woe.
- Unjust, uncharitable as your words,
I pardon them.
- Forgive me, Father.
Discretion does not guide my words.
What peace is there for me!
- In the neighboring district
where lives a holy man,
whose sanctity is marked
with wondrous gifts.
Consult with him.
- Consult a holy man?
Inquire of him?
Good father, wherefore?
What should I inquire?
Must I be taught of him, that sin is woe?
Must I learn that minutes
stamped with crimes
are past recall?
That joys are momentary,
and remorse Eternal?
Death alone can certify whether,
when justice's full dues exacted,
mercy shall grant one
drop to slake my torment.
Here, father, break off.
You to your calling,
I to my tears and mournful occupation.
- Doubt not my friend.
Hardships of war have chased
out the bloom of comeliness
and stamped this face
with harsher lineaments
that well may mock the
prying of a mothers eye.
A mother, through whose firm nerves
tumultuous instinct's flood
ne'er gushed to tell her,
this is your son!
- If not her love, my
lord, suspect her hatred.
Hatred is distempered love.
- Why should she hate me?
For that my opening
passion's swelling ardour
prompted a congenial necessary joy,
was that a cause?
No, Florian, she herself was woman then,
A sensual woman.
She might have pardoned
what she felt so well.
- Forgive me, Edmund, nor think I preach.
You have often told me that night,
the very night that to your arms
gave pretty Beatrice's melting beauties,
was the same night on
which your father died.
- 'Tis true.
Wouldst thou have turned
thee from a willing girl,
to sing a requiem to thy father's soul?
I thought my mother busied with her tears
while I stole to Beatrice's chamber.
How my mother became apprized I know not,
but her heart grew estranged, estranged!
- 'Twas the trick of over-acted sorrow.
Grief fatigues.
- Still must I doubt,
still deem some mystery
beyond a widow's pious artifice.
But, to me her hand is
bounteous as her heart is cold.
Narbonne's revenues are as fully mine
as if I held them by the
strength of charters.
- Why set them on the hazard then?
- I am weary, Florian,
of such a vagrant life.
Befits it me,
sprung from a race of
heroes, Narbonne's prince,
to lend my causal arm's approved valour
to quarrels, nor my country's nor my own?
I fought at Buda 'gainst the Turk,
a holy war, so was it deemed.
I smote the turban'd race.
Mattered it to me whether
crescent or cross prevailed?
- True, my lord.
Deadly feuds for obsolete offences.
- Thy reproof my friend, is just.
But had I not cause a tender
cause, that prompted my return?
This cruel parent, whom
I blame, and mourn,
has won my love, by winning my respect.
She cannot surely, after such perils,
wounds by her command encountered,
after sixteen exiled years,
spurn me when kneeling.
Thinkst thou 'tis possible?
- I would not think it,
but a host of priests surround her.
They, good men, are seldom found
to please the cause of pity.
You shall be beggared,
that the saint your mother may
by cowl'd sychophants
and canting jugglers,
be hailed a new Teresa.
Pray be not seen here.
Let's again to the wars.
- No, Florian.
My dulled soul is sick of riot,
'tis time to bid adieu to vagrant pleasure
and fix the wanderer love.
Domestic bliss.
- Ah, yes, your fair pensioner,
young Adeliza, has
sobered your inconstancy.
Tell me is she must be fruitful.
- Pass we this levity.
'Tis true, Adeliza is
beauty's type renewed.
- Is she kind?
- Cold as the metal bars
that part her from me.
- How gain'd you then admittance?
- This whole month,
while waiting your arrival,
I have haunted her convent's parlour.
O Florian, union with that favoured maiden
might reconcile my mother.
Hark, I hear voices that seem approaching.
They cannot know me, see!
(children singing)
Sweet Children, in whose behalf raises
these little suppliants their
artless hands to heaven?
- You seem a stranger,
or you could but know, sir knight,
that Narbonne's pious
Countess dwells within,
A lady most disconsolate.
Her lord was snatched away
in lusty life's full vantage,
but no account made up!
No absolution!
Hence, his weeping relict
o'eer his spot of doom
a goodly cross erected.
Thither we proceed to
chaunt our holy dirge,
and offer due intercession
for his soul's repose.
- I knew his son.
- Edmund?
Where sojourns he?
- In the grave.
- Is Edmund dead?
Say how.
- He fell at Budapest.
And not to his dishonour.
- Sixteen fatal years has
Narbonne's province groaned
beneath the hand of desolation.
For what crimes we know not!
- I feel your country's woes.
I loved Edmund, revered
his father's ashes.
I will visit this ruined monument
and at our leisure could with
some conference with you.
- This is well.
Where is your haunt?
- A mile without the town
hard by St. Bridget's nunnery.
- There expect me I must to Benedict.
(thunder roaring)
- Return, my gracious lady.
Though the storm abates his
clamours, do not go forth.
I saw the lightning burst on the monument.
The shield of Narbonne's
arms shivered to splinters,
down with hideous crash,
the cross came tumbling.
Then I fled, hark!
Sure I heard a groan!
- Wretches like me, good
Peter, dread no storms.
'Tis my soul's proper language.
Behold she comes a voluntary victim.
Shade of my Narbonne
accept her destined head.
- Oh for pity!
Gracious dame, what words are these?
In any mouth less holy they
would seem a magic incantation.
Last year's eclipse fell out
because your maidens
crossed a gypsy's palm
to know what was become of Beatrice.
Who knows, but sudden
malady took off the damsel?
Beatrice might, or might not,
have sepulture within the castle walls.
- Peace fool.
Thy equivocation has stained my name
with murder's foul suspicion!
Things foreign rise and load
me with their blackness.
Erroneous imputation must be borne,
lest, while unravelling the knotty web,
I lend a clue may vibrate to my heart.
But who comes here?
Retire.
- 'Tis not far off the time the porter
willed me to expect him here.
Oh, Edmund, may my prosperous care
restore thee to thy state.
And aid thy love for Adeliza.
- [Countess] Methought he
spoke of love and Adeliza!
Who can it be?
[Porter] I never heard his name
- Stranger,
did chance or purpose guide thy steps
to this lone dwelling?
- Pardon, gentle lady.
If curious to behold the pious matron
whom Narbonne's plains obey,
I sought this castle.
- Me, stranger.
Is affliction then so rare?
None dwell here but melancholy,
sorrow, and contrition.
- Pleasure has charms,
but so has virtue too.
- Your courtly phrase, young knight,
bespeaks a birth above the vulgar.
- [Porter] Lady, 'tis the hour of prayer.
- Stranger, I'm summoned hence.
At St. Bridget's monastery tomorrow night,
if you can spare some
moments from your pastime,
I would talk with thee in
presence of the abbess.
- So, this is well, my introduction made.
It follows that I move her for her son.
Women often wear the mask
of piety to draw respect,
or hide the loss of it.
While snuffing incense,
and devoutly wanton,
the Pagan goddess grows a Christian saint.
Well!
Edmund, whatso'er thy mother be,
I'll put her virtue or
hypocrisy to the severest tests.
Countess, expect me!
(thunder roaring)
(mournful music)
- The monument destroyed
Well, what of that!
Were every thunderbolt addressed to me,
no one would miss me.
We know the doom we merit.
Fie, fie!
I blush to recollect my weakness.
My Edmund may be dead,
my Adeliza may taste the cup
of woe that I have drugged.
What wretch could be a
blacker criminal than I am?
Were faggots placed around me
and the fatal torch applied
would it teach the world unheard of sins?
How dare I be esteemed?
Be known my crimes!
My Edmund!
Has not a mother's hand
afflicted him enough?
- Madam, young Adeliza
intreats to speak with you.
The lady abbess sickens to death.
- Admit her.
Now my soul recall thy calm.
Approach, sweet maid.
Thy melancholy mein
speaks thy compassionate
and feeling heart.
- Oh, Can I hear this praise,
and not fall in blushes at thy feet?
Recall thy words thy
Adeliza merits no encomium.
I am not innocent!
- Thou dearest orphan to my bosom come.
Purity like thine affrights
itself with fancied guilt.
- In vain you cheer me.
I am most unworthy.
Other discourse than thine
has charmed mine ear,
nor dare I now presume
to call thee mother.
- My lovely innocence, restrain thy tears.
I know thy secret.
Know, why beats and
throbs thy little heart
with unaccustomed tumult.
- Impossible!
- I will tell it thee.
Thou hast conversed with a young knight.
- Amazement!
Who informed thee?
Pent in her chamber, sickness has detained
our abbess from the parlour.
There I saw him of as he came alone.
- He talked of love?
- He did.
- 'Tis well, this is the
stranger I beheld this morning.
- He sorrows for a father.
Something too he uttered
of a large inheritance
that should be his.
- Dost thou love this stranger?
- Yes, with such love
as that I feel for thee.
His earnest words sound like the precepts
of a tender parent.
And next to thee, I
think I could obey him.
- Be calm, my lovely orphan!
Hush thy fears.
Heaven knows how fondly,
anxiously, I love thee!
The stranger's not to blame.
Myself will task him, and
see if he deserves thee.
Now retire, nor slack thy
duty to the expiring saint.
(chorus singing)
- The dew of grace rest on this dwelling.
- Thanks, my ghostly friend.
- Or I mistake, in your sad eye,
I spell affliction's signature.
- To tutor my unapt and
ill-schooled nature,
you come then, with
doctrines and authority.
If ought can medicate
a soul unsound as mine.
- You mock my friendship,
and miscall my zeal.
Learn the measure of your woes.
Learn, if the mother's fortitude
can brave the bolt the
woman's arrogance defied.
- The mother, said'st thou?
- Yes, imperious dame.
On Buda's plain thy
slaughtered Edmund lies.
An unbeliever's weapon cleft his heart.
- In the grave, thou
sayest, my Edmund sleeps.
How didst thou learn his fate?
Priest, mock me not!
- Then you loved him?
- Loved him!
Oh, nature, bleeding at my heart,
hearest thou this?
Loved him?
Ha!
I am thy mistress yet,
nor will I brook insolent reproof.
Produce thy warrant,
assure my Edmund's death
or dread his vengeance!
- My warrant is at hand.
This gentleman beheld thy Edmund
breathless on the ground.
- Hah, Is this sorcery?
Or is my husband?
(laughter)
- Look up, o ever dear!
Behold thy son, it is thy Edmund's voice.
Dumb still!
I have killed her!
My brain grows hot.
- My lord, restrain your passion.
See, She revives.
- Art thou, or not, a mother?
- Hah, who, where am I?
Why did you hold me?
Was it not my Narbonne?
- Alas, she raves!
- Hah, whom!
Quick, answer.
Count of Narbonne, dost thou live?
- Madam, behold your son.
He kneels for pardon.
- Distraction!
What means this complicated
scene of horrors?
Art thou my husband winged from other orbs
to taunt my soul?
What is this dubious form?
Art thou my dead or my living son?
- I am thy living Edmund.
Let these scalding tears
attest the existence
of thy suffering son.
- Ah, touch me not!
- How?
In that cruel breast revive then
all sensations except affection?
But now, thy eyes I seemed my father?
At least for that
resemblance, sake embrace me.
- Horror on horror!
Blasted be thy tongue.
- Lady, I doubt not your blessing
first obtained and gracious pardon,
he will obey your pleasure,
and return to stranger climes.
- 'Tis false.
I will not hence.
Am I not Narbonne's prince?
Who will banish me?
- Edmund, hear me!
Thou art my son, and
I will prove a mother.
But I am thy sovereign too.
This state is mine.
Benedict, attend me.
Tomorrow, Edmund, shalt
thou learn my pleasure.
- Why, this is majesty.
Commanding sex!
Strength, courage, all
our boasted attributes
seems a borrowed ray,
when virtue deigns to
speak with female organs.
Yes, o my mother, I will learn to obey.
Make but the blooming Adeliza mine,
And bear, of me unquestioned,
Narbonne's scepter.
'Till life's expiring lamp
resumes its wasted oil no more.
(chorus singing)
- I know thy spirit well.
But 'till this hour I
have not seen thy passions
boil o'er the bounds of prudence.
- Mistake me not, good brother
I would not know one half that I suspect
'till I have acted as if not suspecting.
'Tis time enough to make up our account,
when we confess and kneel for absolution.
- Still does thy genius
soar above mankind!
How many fathers of our holy
church in Benedict I view.
- No flattery, brother
'Tis true the church owes
Benedict some thanks.
For her, I forgot I am a man.
Enemies to roam our Benedict's foes.
Interest bids us crush this
cockatrice and her egg.
Already to those vagrants she inclines
as if the rogues, that
preach reform to others,
like idiots, minded to reform themselves.
- Be cautious, brother,
you may lose the lady.
- She is already lost.
I cannot dupe, and
therefore must destroy her.
- How may this be accomplished?
- Ask me not.
I guess her fatal secret.
- I tremble!
- Dastard, tremble if we fail.
Peace, dotard, peace!
Nor when the lamb is
nigh, must eagles wrangle.
Why sighs that gentle bosom?
- Ah, holy father, the
pious abbess is at peace.
We go to bear her parting
blessing to the Countess.
- It must not be by me.
She wills you restrain your steps
within the cloister's pale,
nor grant access but
to one stranger knight.
The Countess commands.
- Hah, Adeliza!
I charged thee guard thy convent.
Wherefore then this disobedience?
- Madam, I was urging the
fitness of your orders.
- No, I am the thing you made me.
Crush me, spurn me I will not murmur.
Should you bid me die I know
'twere meant in kindness.
- Bid thee die!
My own detested life
but lingers round thee!
My child, retire I am much discomposed.
- Be patient lady.
This fair domain, thou know'st,
acknowledges the
sovereignty of the church.
Thy rebel son dres not attempt.
- Again I bid thee peace.
There is no question of Lord Edmund.
Leave us,
I have to talk with her alone.
Now tremble at voices supernatural
and forfeit the spoils the
tempest throws into our lap.
Now,
Adeliza,
summon all thy courage,
retrace my precepts past
nor let a tear profane a moment
that's worth a martyrdom.
- The virgin veil shall
guard my spotless hours,
assure my peace, and
saint me for hereafter.
- It cannot be.
To Narbonne thou must bid a last adieu!
And with the stranger
knight depart a bride.
- Unhappy me?
Too sure I have over
burthened thy charity,
if thou wouldst drive me from hence,
restrain thy alms, dear lady.
- O Adeliza,
thy words now slake and
now augment my fever!
Hear my last breath.
Avoid the scorpion pleasure.
Death lurks beneath the velvet of his lip.
O retrospect of horror.
To the altar haste, Adeliza!
Vow thou wilt be wretched!
- Does thou then doom
me to eternal sorrows?
Hast thou deceived me?
- How she melts me!
What have I said?
Oh lovely innocence,
thou art my only thought.
Oh was I formed the child of sin?
And I dare not embrace thee?
Yet curse the hour that
stamped thee with a being!
- Alas, was I then born the child of sin?
Who were my parents?
I will pray for them?
- Oh, if the bolt must
come, let it strike me here!
- Oh, raise thee from the earth.
What is my lot?
Wilt thou yet cherish me?
- Ah, canst thou doubt
this conflict of the soul?
Oh, 'tis to shield thee
from this world of sorrows
that thou must flee, must wed,
must never view the
towers of Narbonne more,
must never know The doom
reserved for thy sad patroness.
Fly, 'ere my rage forget distinction,
nature and make a medley
of unheard-of crimes.
Fly, ere it be too late.
- Alas, she raves.
I will call for help.
- She's gone.
That pang, great God,
was my last sacrifice.
Now recollect thyself.
My soul consummate the pomp of horror
with tremendous coolness.
'Tis fit that reason,
punish passion's crime.
Reason!
Alas, 'tis one of my convulsions.
Down I sink, lost in eternal torment.
- She is not here.
Shall we not follow her?
- Thou knows't her not.
Her transport is fictitious.
- I tremble for her life.
- Thou art young.
I know this Countess,
an arrant heretic.
She scoffs the church.
Her days are numbered,
and thou shalt do wisely to quit her.
- Alas, She bids me go.
She bids me wed the stranger knight
that woo'd me at our parlour.
- And thou shalt take her at her word.
Myself with joining your hands and lo!
In happy hour, who comes to meet her boon?
- In tears!
That cowl shall not protect
the injurious tongue,
that dare insult thy innocence.
- My gracious lord,
yourself and virgin coyness
must be chidden.
- Unriddle, priest.
My soul is too impatient to wait
the impertinence of flowery dialect.
Dost thou consent,
sweet passion of my soul?
- Forebear!
It must not be.
Thou shalt not wed a beggar.
This orphan, this abandoned wanderer,
taunted with poverty,
with shameful origin.
- Lovely Adeliza placed in your arms
can never feel affliction.
This the good Countess knows.
- By my sire's soul I will not thank her.
Has she dared to scorn thee,
Thou beauteous excellence?
In her very presence I will espouse thee.
- By heaven all's lost
should they meet now.
Pray be advised heaven knows
how dear I tender your felicity.
The chapel is a few paces hence.
Arrived there, I will speedily
pronounce a few solemn words.
- Well, be it so.
My fair one, this holy man advises well.
- Yes,
heaven, to thee I fly.
Thou art my only refuge.
- The business is dispatched.
Their hands are joined.
The puling moppet
struggled with her wishes,
invoked each saint to witness
her refusal nor heeded,
though I swore their golden harps
were tuned to greet her hymenal hours.
The impetuous Count would
have forerun the rites.
The maid, affrighted,
at such tumultuous unaccustomed onset,
sunk lifeless on the pavement.
Thus am I revenged.
Proud dame of Narbonne, lo!
A bare-foot monk thus pays thy scorn,
thus vindicates his altars.
- Ah, woe of woe!
Good father, haste thee in.
And speak sweet words of
comfort to our mistress
her brain is much disturbed.
- Goodman exorcist.
Thy pains are unavailing.
Her sins press her.
Guilt has unhinged her reason.
- She raves upon her son and
thinks he came in vision.
- 'Twas no vision.
- How?
- He has spoken with her.
- Go to, it could not be.
- I tell thee, Edmund,
thy quondam master's
son has seen his mother.
- Oh, joyous sounds!
Where is my noble lord?
- Here and undone.
- These sixteen years has my friend Edmund
pined in banishment
while masses, mummings,
goblins and processions
usurp'd his heritage,
and made of Narbonne A
theatre of holy interludes
and fainted frauds.
But day darts on these spells.
The enlightened age
eschews such vile deceits
and truth shall do mankind,
and Edmund, justice.
- I dare not shoot the gulph.
Ha, Benedict
thou art a priest, thy
mission should be holy.
Quick, do thy work.
'Tis not the wound, it is the consequence!
- Split, my heart, at this sad sight.
- Stand off, thou art an accomplice.
Madam, it was your
morning's gracious pleasure
that I should attend you.
- Ha, who are thou?
- Have you forgot me, lady?
- Memory is full.
A head distract as mine
can hold only two objects,
guilt and eternity!
- He is returned,
your son, have you not seen him?
- Would I had never!
- This villainous monk has
stepped twixt you and nature.
And misreported of the noblest gentleman
that treads on Christian ground.
Are you a mother?
- Ye saints!
This was the demon prompted it, avaunt!
He beckons me.
I will not, lies my lord
wounded in the porch?
I'll tear my hair and bathe his wounds.
My strength, my reason
fail, darkness surrounds me!
Let me die here.
- This is too much for art.
- No, 'tis fictitious all
'twas I inspired the horrors
she has been so kind to
utter at my suggestion.
Artful woman Thou subtle
emblem of thy sex,
composed of madness and deceit,
but since thy brain has lost its poise,
I will send those shall
shake it beyond recovery
of its reeling bias.
- This interval is well.
'tis thy last boon, tremendous Providence!
And I will use it as 'twere
the elixir of descending mercy.
A woman's words, a mother's woe!
But honor if I believe this
garb, is thy profession.
- A soldier's honor is his virtue.
A soldier and his honor exist
together, and together perish.
- 'Tis enough.
Nor suffer the ebbing
moments more inquiry.
Adeliza, my orphan shall be thine.
Nay, start not, sir, your
loves are known to me.
- I love Adeliza?
Lady, recall thy wandering mind.
Tho's the licentious
camp and rapine's holiday
have been my school,
deem not so reprobate my morals,
that my eye would note no distance
between the harlot's glance
and my friend's bride.
- Thy friend?
What friend?
- Lord Edmund.
- What of him?
- Is Adeliza's lord,
her wedded bridegroom.
- Confusion!
Phrenzy, blast me, all ye furies.
Edmund and Adeliza!
When?
Where?
How?
Edmund and Adeliza!
Quick, unsay the monstrous tale.
Oh, prodigy of ruin.
Does my own son then
boil with fiercer fires
then scorched his impious
mother's madding veins?
- What means this agony?
Didst thou not grant the
maiden to his wishes?
- Did I not couple distinctions horrible.
Plan unnatural rites to
grace my funeral pile,
and meet the furies.
- Amazement!
Will hasten grant, ye powers,
my speed be not too late!
- Dear parent, look on us,
and bless your children.
- My children!
Horror!
Horror, yes, ye are my children!
Edmund loose that hand,
'tis poison to thy soul!
Hell has no venom like a child's touch!
Oh, agonizing thought!
Who made this marriage?
Whose unhallowed breath
pronounced the incestuous sounds?
- Incest, good heavens!
- Yes, thou devoted victim!
Let thy blood curdle to stone!
Perdition circumvents thee.
Oh, where this monster stands!
Thy mother!
Mistress!
Mother of thy daughter, sister, wife!
The pillar of accumulated horrors!
Hear and tremble!
- Yes, I do tremble, though
thy words are phrenzy.
So black must be the
passions that inspired it.
- O Edmund, I have burst
the bond of every tie
when thou shalt know the
fullness of my crimes
to which this fury did involve thy youth,
it will seem piety to curse me, Edmund.
Oh!
Impious night!
Hah, Is not that my lord?
He shakes the curtains
of the nuptial couch,
and starts to find a son there!
- Gracious heaven!
Grant that these shocking
images be raving!
- Sweet lady, be composed.
Benedict shall discharge our vows.
- For a short interval give me reason.
Heaven, it must be known
the fullness of my crime.
Ye know how fondly my luxurious
fancy doated upon my lord.
For eighteen months, an embassy
detained him from my bed.
A harbinger announced his near return.
Love dressed his image
to my longing thoughts
in all its warmest colors.
But the morn,
in which impatience
grew almost to sickness,
presented him a bloody corpse before me.
I raved!
The storm of disappointed passions
severed all my reason,
assailed all my blood.
Whether too warmly
pressed, or too officious,
to turn the torrent of my grief aside,
Beatrice that attended me,
disclosed thy suit,
unhappy boy!
- What is to come?
Shield me, ye gracious
powers from my own thoughts.
- My fancy saw thee thy father's image.
- Swallow the accursed sound!
Nor dare to say.
- Yes, thou polluted son!
Grief, disappointment, opportunity,
raised such a tumult in my madding blood,
I took Beatrice's place.
And while thy arms
twined, to thy thinking,
round another's waist,
hear, hell, and tremble
thou didst clasp thy mother!
(screams)
- Oh, execrable!
- Be that swoon eternal!
Nor let her know the rest.
She is thy daughter,
fruit of that monstrous night!
- Infernal woman!
My dagger must repay, a tale like this
no, I must not strike.
I dare not punish what you dared commit.
- Oh, give me the dagger,
my arm will not recoil.
Thus, Edmund, I revenge thee!
- Help!
Hoa, help!
- Peace and conceal our shame.
Quick, frame some legend.
Assist the maid an accident.
- Mercy, heaven!
Who did this deed?
- Myself.
- What was the cause?
- Follow me to yon gulph,
and thou shall know.
I answer not to man.
- Bethink thee, lady.
- Thought ebbs apace.
O Edmund, could a blessing
break from my lips,
and not become a curse, I would.
Poor Adeliza, 'tis accomplishd!
- My lord, explain these horrors.
Wherefore fell your mother?
And why faints your wife?
- My wife?
Thou damning priest!
I have no wife, thou knows't it.
Thou gavest me indeed
no, rot my tongue ere the
dread sound escape it!
Bear away that hateful monk.
- Who was the prophet now?
Remember me!
- O Florian,
we must haste to where
fell war must war assumes
its ugliest form.
I burn to rush on death!
O tender friend!
I must not violate thy guiltless ear!
Ha, 'tis my father calls!
I dare not see him!
- Be composed, my lord
We are all your friends.
Let us comfort your gentle bride.
- Forbid it, all ye powers.
O Florian, bear her to the holy sisters.
Say, 'twas my mother's
will she take the veil.
I must never behold her.
Never more review this
fear of monstrous guilt.
No, to the embattled foe I
will present this hated form.
Welcome be the saber that
leaves no atom of it undefaced.
(bells chiming)
(thunder roaring)
(applause)
(laughter)
- When did you know in
public or in private
double entrendres my
strict virtue drive at.
Your muses sir, I'm not more
free from ill on Mt. Parnassus
or on Strawberry Hill.
And though with her
repentance you may hum one,
I who not play your
countess to become one.
So very guilty, and so very good
an angel with such errant flesh and blood
such sinning, praying, preaching,
I'll be kissed if I don't
think she was a methodist.
(laughter)
Saints are the produce of a viscous age.
Crimes must abound to ere
secretaries can rage.
His mask no canting confessor assumes
with acted zeal no flaming bigot fumes.
'Til the rich harvest nods
with the swelling grain,
and the sharp sickle can assure his gain.
But soon shall hypocrites,
their flights deplore
nor grim enthusiasts vex Britannia more.
Virtue shall guard her
daughters from their arts,
shine in their eyes and
blossom in their hearts.
They need no lectures and fantastic tone,
their lesson lives before
them on the throne.
(applause)
- So I have the honor to
introduce you our fabulous cast
Georgina Lock as the Countess of Narbonne.
(applause)
Carlos Guanche as Edmund.
Gilberto Saenz as Florian.
(applause)
Chelsea Phillips as Adeliza.
Charlie Gillespie as Benedict.
(applause)
Justin Crisp as Friar Martin.
Dale Townshend as Peter the Porter.
(applause)
Stephen Clarke as the servant.
And David Worall who
has abridged our text.
(applause)
And also Jill Campbell
who has read our prologue.
(applause)
And finally Misty Anderson.
(applause and cheering)
And we're gonna do a talk
back in just a few minutes.
We're gonna just do a
quick, bring us some chairs.
So please stay for that.
- And some of our actors will need to go
hang up these very hot clothes,
but they will come back
in for the discussion.
And we're planning on
maybe 20 minutes in here
and then we'd like you to
join us at a reception after.
- Yes.
- Thank you.
(applause)
- While the cast is getting changed,
we can get started.
I'm Catherine Sheehy, I'm
the Resident Dramaturg
of Yale rep and I'm the chair of the
Department of Dramaturgy
and Dramatic Criticism
at the Yale School of Drama,
and 18th century British enthusiast.
I'm delighted to welcome
you here to a talk back.
I'll ask you a couple of questions,
and then I'll throw it open to you.
So that, just because we're recording it,
there are standers by with microphones.
So when you're called upon,
if you would just contain your enthusiasm
until the microphone can
get to you, that'd be great.
I wanted to read to you
just a little bit from
Horace Walpoles post
script to the 1791 edition
which is about 23 years
after the play was originally written.
From the time that I first
undertook the foregoing scenes
I never flattered myself
that they would be proper
to appear on the stage.
The subject's so horrid that
I thought it would shock
rather than give
satisfaction to the audience.
Still I found it so truly tragic
in the essential springs
of terror and pity
that I could not resist the impulse
of adapting it to the scene,
but could never be practicable
to produce it there.
(laughter)
See.
See how wrong we can be 300 years later.
I saw that it would
admit of great situation
of lofty characters
and of those sudden and unforeseen strokes
which have often singular effect
in operating a revolution in the passions,
and in interesting the spectator.
It was capable of furnishing
not only a contrast
of characters, but a
contrast of virtue and vice
in the same character,
sitting right there.
And by laying the scene
in what age and country I pleased,
Catholic France,
pictures of ancient manners might be drawn
and many illusions to
historic events introduced
to bring the action nearer the
imagination of the spectator.
The moral resulting from
the calamities attended
on unbounded passions, obviously
the moral of the story,
even to the destruction
of the criminal's race
was obviously suited to the
purpose and object of tragedy.
So I thought that would be a
good place for us to start,
since we have some scholars up here.
I wanted to ask, is the
mysterious mother a tragedy.
What is the place, purpose
and object would you say.
I would be happy to
throw it out to anybody
who'd like to answer.
- Well, I think,
there's a kind of a textual fault line
in the play
when we conceptualize it as a tragedy.
On the one hand he mentions
aristotelian categories
of pity and terror,
and harking back to an aristotelian
understanding of tragedy
in the post script that you've just read.
But on the other hand, as the
prologue to a piece makes clear
he is trying to differentiate himself
from classism and indeed
French neo classism
of the 18th century
which subscribes to
aristotelian models of tragedy
and in fact holds Shakespeare responsible
for deviating from those
and seeing him as kind
of gothic and barbaric
and uncouth and uncivilized
because he doesn't conform
to notions of tragedy.
So I think the place
relationship to tragedy
is complex on the one hand,
citing pity and terror and the well spring
aristotelian categories.
But on the other hand,
differentiating himself
certainly from neo classical
conceptualizations of tragedy.
Therefore, Shakespeare serves him
as the kind of guide and
the model to a tragic mode.
And the play is replete
with references to Macbeth
to Hamlet in particular.
I think those are the models
to which he turns bearing in mind
for the 18th century
Shakespeare is the gothic bard,
gothic in a very different sense, yes.
- So essentially an Englishman
wanted to let us know
the French got it wrong?
- Yes.
- Yup, that's very odd.
- As he does in the preface to “Otranto”.
- Right, well Walpole actually courted,
comparisons to Shakespeare
as his literary target of aspiration
as Jill read in the prologue.
Here he's taken that old
Shakespearian chestnut
the bed trick, and he's inverted right
as a seat of disaster
rather than the wake
of the comic resolution
as it is in all is well
and somewhat less merrily
in measure for measure.
Maybe you can talk a little bit about
describing the bed trick, Georgina
and what kind emotions that you go through
while you're imagining that old chestnut.
- The bed trick.
Well, I don't have a son,
but I've got quite a good imagination.
(laughter)
I kind of like the lines
where she's moving between
loving what she sees as a son
and at the same time being disgusted.
Loving what she sees as a husband
and being disgusted by her son,
which is quite an interesting
position to be in.
And I suppose that it's,
I mean I can't really think
of anything worse to do
apart from murder.
So I'm in a very difficult place really.
And I also think it's
slightly weird to sleep
with somebody the night
that somebody dies anyway.
So I did find it quite difficult
to get in to her from the inside,
but the more I'd read the script,
and the more I kind of read
the language of the script
and the things about guilt and innocence
and the rhetoric that she uses,
it helped me to kind of use the script
to just kind of portray
what she's going through
then sometimes you start to feel it
and actually what I used
to try to get closer to it,
I mean we talked about the spine
in which it kind of keeping
the spine very straight
and then bending.
The idea of being disgusted by yourself,
your stomach starts to kind of shrink
and want to kind of vomit by
the idea of what you've done
and that kind of physical clue
helped me with getting closer
to that
well let's call it a sin, it's a sin.
(laughs)
- This also sort of touches on,
meaning the moments of nervous
laughter as you might imagine
and we only got together on
Monday night for the first time.
But we sorta had to speed
through the process.
And in thinking about this sort of,
the horrific bed trick
we're also back to your first
question in a way Catherine
is this a tragedy?
The over-the-topness of it
which is also something that,
especially for those scholars in the room
who teach “Otranto” to undergraduates.
Is this funny when the helmet falls right?
And crushes the son.
Is something absurd around the corner.
So we are comparing the musical version.
(laughter)
We'll have lots of Mama Mia tunes.
- The old tap dancing mysterious mother.
Walpole said that he
never flattered himself
the play would be proper
to appear on the stage
and setting aside the unlikelihood
that he never flattered himself,
did you find the play stage
worthy for today's loosh
depraved audience, like these people here.
And how did you go about
making it stage worthy.
- Well that's certainly David.
- The thing that I did of course,
because it started out as a fire back
Shakespearean play,
Shakespearean shape,
and so I realized that you know,
you wouldn't want to
stay around for two hours
or something like that,
so we need to get it down.
So I had to cut it,
which is brutal,
but then I found a performance
after Walpole's death
where it had been performed as three acts.
So I knew it could be cut,
and I guess I thought probably
it should be cut as well.
So that's why I did that.
So I
threw out things really.
So what you're really doing
is trying to end with the final scene.
So it's a bit like landing
an aircraft to think.
There's a landing strip
which is the final scene
with the Countess and you
have to throw out all the
luggage and the drinks, trolley,
and everything in order
to be able to reach that.
But an interesting thing began to happen
as I worked through it.
Which is that once you
throw out all the positives
and you accent all the negatives
like the reverse of the song,
what you get then is this
kind of melodramatic line
which seems to go through it.
So it's kind of ideology
is freighted on this line
of melodrama actually,
interaction which I hope this
cutting has kind of done really.
And it's interesting
that it's there at all.
'Cause you can see Horace
kind of making melodrama
as a kind of again, a
spine going through it
even though the play is
probably about other things
profound things about guilt and
religion and all those things,
but that line seems to
go all the way through it
as I kind of worked through
it and shortened it.
- Yeah, and in our early conversations
when you mentioned melodrama
and we have a wonderful
lighting design candidate
at my home University, Alice Trent,
and she did these graphics for us.
So that got me thinking
just about melodrama
as the over the topness
but also might music do some work
to supply what had to be caught here.
And a lot of what had to be cut,
I see Charlie and Justin are back,
is the religious struggle
that Walpole is staging here,
imagining this early reformation
or almost pre-reformation
moment and coming back.
So all of these zingers
about an enlightened age
and reason are also in the context
of a very fascinating
kind of anticlericalism
that it is also a fascination
with all things catholic and
a kind of pre modern past.
So we were just looking
for ways to give that feel
even though those debates
and the play and those lines
which are very interesting
might not be the most playable.
- To get back to the notion
of disgust which you picked up
is I think is hugely important
and interesting in this play
is to look at how that term for Walpole
certainly in the context of this play
is inseparable from
a perception of female sexuality.
And what seems to happen in
correspondence around the play
that he undertakes particularly
with this friend Mason
is a concern with disgust.
And it's quite clear that that disgust
pertains to the fact that this is a woman
who has not unconsciously
committed a tragic error
but someone who desires, who is desiring,
and who is a kind of sexual agent
and who chooses
voluntarily and consciously
her son as a bed partner.
And it is that element of
disgust that Mason suggests
he rewrite out of the play
and turn it into an
unconscious tragic mistake.
But it's quite clear that
the issue around disgust
pertains to Walpole to a consciously,
deliberately desiring woman,
which I think he has
difficulties conceptualizing,
as of course many of the
late 18th century do.
- It's about that women
can't be trusted as well
especially when sexually powerful
the kind of last trick
that women can play.
- But also, in the history of sexuality,
it's only at around this
time that women are being
given a sexuality of their own anyway
and not seen simply as inverted
desiring bodies
that have sort of organs and desires
that are simply inverted
versions of the masculine.
But the two sex model of desiring arises
in the late 18th century
where women are kind of bestowed
with their own sexuality
and that I think, is obviously threatening
for someone like Walpole.
- And these are words that Edmund uses.
He calls his mother a sensual woman.
And it refers to organs.
I think so.
- Such a play is never done
until the bodies of the
women are strewn on the stage
and then supremely sorry.
(laughter)
I think we should we open up
for questions from the
audience if there are any.
I mean I have some more but I don't wanna
usurp your curiosity.
- Oh, we do have the remainder
of the cast back in there
if you have questions.
- They can take questions too as well.
Yes right here.
- [Viewer] Well, I was
quite intrigued by this
issue of female sexuality
and lust on which the
whole plot turns obviously.
And is this treated in
other literary works at the time?
Or is it treated, I
don't know, from the popehood
is it treated in philosophical
writings at the time?
Forgive me, I don't know much about it
but it just.
- Yes most definitely.
- I think you can see in
Gertrude too, I mean in Hamlet.
You were talking about Hamlet.
The deep suspicion of a woman who,
particularly a woman who has certain age
who continues to desire.
You've been through the
restoration with people like
Mrs. Loveit in “Man of Mode”
and this kind of the older woman sexuality
is like a death bed for male scene.
You know what I mean?
And it's seen as a kind of problem.
- I think that starts
in the renaissance stage
on the Shakespearean stage.
- In the age as well,
sometime in the 1780s,
there's a play called
“The Mysterious Husband,”
that's about incest as well
but in not quite the same way.
And the storyline in that is that
the English father has a mistress in Paris
and then his adult son,
who is estranged from
the father goes to Paris
and he takes up with the mistress
unbeknownst to each other.
So there's a kind of a,
I guess in that period,
they're exploring the limits of incest.
So London audiences
kind of comfortable with
thinking about that I think.
Perhaps they're exploring,
there are probably other incest plays
of the 18th century that I don't know.
Dryden’s “Oedipus” for example.
But this notion of the kind of dangerously
desiring woman would become
a staple of gothic fiction
in the late 18th century
and all those invariably to
catastrophic dramatic ends.
From Ann Radcliff to
Charlotte Dacre and beyond.
These images of passion,
the word, they become
associated with is passion
which has both sentimental overtones
but also sexual overtones.
- And in just thinking
specifically about the stage
I mean it's at the restoration
that we have women playing
women's parts for the first time
in English theater.
And restoration comedies, those comedies
between 1660 and about 1700
are known for being especially
sexually frank, dirty.
There's lots of adultery,
there's lots of sleeping around
and that sort of all comes on
in a burst after Charles
II reopens the theaters
after the puritans had closed them.
So there's a kind of cultural revenge plot
on the puritans that's
going on, right, yay!
The puritans are gone, we
can have sexy comedies.
But also women's bodies on the stage
and then that peak dies down
but we still have some of those types
that are part of again, discovering
what the stage does when
women are embodying women.
- But what is interesting too
is taking the bed trick from
that bawdy tradition
that comic bawdy tradition
of say William Wycherley
and then repurposing it to tragic ends.
- And I think too that if you think about
the theater in London
was a commercial idea
and the people who began to have money
were of course then the merchant class,
and the merchant class wanted
to see themselves on stage
and then they aspired to
the toys of the aristocracy
but with the morals of the bourgeoisie
and so you get fetishization.
And I think the sentimental
comedy goes a long way
toward the gothic.
Like you get the conscious lovers
and then you just put it amphetamines
and you get “The Mysterious Mother.”
(laughter)
- I like that.
- Other questions?
Yes, Stephen yeah.
- [Viewer] Is there not a contrast
between the absolute
fundamental to the disgust
and fear of female sexuality
which one suspects has real personal,
relevance or resonance rather for Walpole.
And the other main sort
of obvious theme comes out
in terms of catholicism
and anticatholicism
which is infinitely more layered
and where he seems to be using, is a trope as it were?
It's a device which uses
in order to achieve dramatic effect.
It's mental it's not felt.
- I think that's a good question.
And were Charlie Gillespie down here,
I would make him answer it.
Yeah, I think that that's
an important distinction
whatever disgust is,
particularly Walpole and
his possible sexuality
in his disgust at the idea of woman
and the religious debate
that's playing out here.
But I think the intersecting
Benedict, you know
for Rome, I forgot I am a man.
The kind of outsiderness
to heterosexuality.
- But I think the difference is that
in relation to Catholicism,
Walpole can never safely adopt
an unequivocal attitude of disgust
in the way that he can in
relation to femininity.
It's much more ambivalent
in relation to catholicism,
not least of all because of catholicism's
architectural heritage
that's he's deliberately caught in
at Strawberry Hill.
There's a very problematic
attempt of Walpole
to distinguish between the
aesthetics of catholicism
and its theological legacy.
So the disgust is never is as abject
in relation to catholicism.
- [Viewer] It's part of the [indistinct].
- Oh absolutely.
- Oh I would say yes,
and at least at the architectural
and aesthetic level,
obsessed.
- But I think you can
just see also anti French
as well, which is the
feeling of the period.
And so you go through that as a line.
And I think that was bought.
It becomes explorable.
And again, “The Mysterious Husband,”
you know the mistress is in Paris,
that kind of thing going on
in the 18th century England
where the French are the enemy.
- And we read the
prologue and the epilogue
that Walpole wrote for his own play
and the bit that I read he wrote
imagining Kitty Clive doing it
and then take that down
a bit methodist as well.
So I said, of course I have to take this.
I think that they are again,
we're coming back to
the religious context
and we can't undersell that.
Even if we had to leave some of that
on the cutting room floor
to get this play in this space.
- Yes, yes.
- [Viewer] How did you get together
a cast from so many different places?
(laughter)
- Persistence.
We planned ahead
and I twisted arms in many cases,
and Cindy Roman too,
and we put our heads together
and thought about people
who have connection
to the Lewis Walpole Library
and people who might
be available and around
for which they were so
generous with their time.
Joe Roach helped me find those fantastic
young men, and Carlos is here,
and Gilberto had to go.
So we wove it together and we did truly,
just get together for the
first time on Monday night.
- And one more question, yes right here.
- [Viewer] Thank you.
I noticed that the
actress who played Adeliza
is quite the high maiden.
(laughter)
And I wanted to ask a question with her.
Walpole was most unhappy
with Adeliza, wasn't he?
He did say, that he was not so happy,
he really loved the play
but he did say that the character
hadn't come up quite right
and it's really very interesting to do
(laughter)
doing so little.
- [Chelsea] Can everybody hear
me if I don't use the mic.
- Use the mic.
- [Chelsea] Oh sorry.
It is a bit hard, and in
part because of the wonderful
cutting that David gave us,
which is very playable.
I sort of have this
pattern where I come on
and I kneel and I cry
and then I leave.
And use what's happening
on stage around me.
So sure, there isn't a lot to do
but actually as I was able to watch us
sort of move through the
whole arch of the story
over the last couple of days,
I started to realize more and more.
And I think there is
something very relatable
about the fact that
Adeliza is so dependent on the Countess
with sort of everything in her life,
including all of her sort
of emotional well being.
And so when the countess
starts to break down,
I think there seems to
be a lot of inconsistency
in Adeliza, is she excited
about being married?
Does she not wanna get married?
Does she wanna be from a nun?
Does she like this mysterious
young man that she's met.
It's unclear, but I think
what it ultimately comes down to
is that she wants to please the Countess.
And so whatever the
Countess is telling her,
including dooming yourself
by getting married,
she's gonna say, "Okay, I'll do that."
- Again, to mention the conscious lovers,
again you're gonna think of Indiana.
The orphan who is revealed
to have either the key to
happiness or the key to ruin
in the play.
I think, we wanna release
you to the reception
and the wine and the cheese,
and congratulating the actors
as you encounter them in the room,
but thank you very much for staying.
(applause)
(angelic music)
(light music)